seit zwei jahren sucht die
wissenschaftliche initiative
breakthrough listen also quasi
durchbruch hören nach außerirdischen
signalen jetzt hat sie extrem seltsame
signale entdeckt und gleich 15 von ihnen
es handelt sich um fast radiopreis
schneller radio blitze die extrem
seltsam sind bisheriger
astrophysikalische erklärung die
funktionieren also nicht mehr wenn so
viele radio blitze in einer zeitspanne
von lediglich fünf stunden entdeckt
werden was diese signale so besonders
macht und wie es weitergeht jetzt in
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen das signal fast ray burst 12
11 0 2 kurz fr b 12 02 ist wirklich sehr
seltsam es stammt aus einer metall am
zwerggalaxien und ist etwa drei
milliarden lichtjahre von uns entfernt
das heißt diese signale wurden
ausgesandt als hier auf der erde gerade
mal ein paar einzeller herum schon
es dauerte noch eine weitere milliarde
jahre bis die ersten mehrzeller
entstanden von menschlichem leben mal
ganz abgesehen aber wie kann es dann
sein dass aus dieser galaxie ständig
diese extrem kurzen radio signale
ausgesandt werden es gibt zahlreiche
astrophysikalische theorien aber sie
alle können nicht erklären wie sich
ein solches signal ständig wiederholen
kann andere fass rainbirds sind dann
auch nur ein mal aufgetreten und dann
nie wieder was ist hier anders für die
breakthrough insel initiative ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit deshalb hoch dass es
ein signal einer intelligenten spezies
sein könnte eine art backen signale
seien funkfeuer das warnung soll oder
eine art ortsschild ist es könnte aber
auch eine zivilisation sein die die
energie eines ganzen sterns nutzen kann
um zum beispiel riesige raumtransporter
mit solchen radio blitzen anzutreiben
für zivilisation gibt es die katastophe
skala sie besagt welche energie eine
zivilisation nutzen kann
die menschheit ist hier knapp unter dem
wert 1 weil wir knapp die gesamte
energie unseres heimatplaneten nutzen
können ab dem werk 2 kann eine
zivilisation die energie seines
zentralgestirns nutzen und ab dem wert 3
die der gesamten heimat galaxie eine
katastophe zwei zivilisation könnte mit
hilfe ihres zentralsterns solche radio
blitze aus senden und als antrieb für
raumschiffe
fab 12 11 02 wurde 2012 entdeckt und
erst ein paar jahre später wurden in
den beobachtungsdaten die
wiederkehrenden fps gefunden aber so
viele radio blitze wie jetzt mit dem
green bank radioteleskop in west
virginia in den usa beobachtet wurden
die gab es noch nie in so kurzer zeit
und noch etwas ist besonders an den
neuen radio blitzen sie senden mit einer
frequenz von 7 gigahertz das ist eine
höhere frequenz als bisher und das
forschungsteam hat jetzt viel mehr daten
mit dem digital backend instrument des
green bank teleskop konnten jetzt
verschiedene gigahertz frequenzen
gleichzeitig aufgezeichnet werden
sie werden jetzt in millionen einzelne
kanäle aufgeteilt und stück für
stück untersucht das kann jahre dauern
aber mit diesen daten sondern endlich
herausgefunden werden wie die fabis die
schnellen radio blitze entstehen und
vielleicht findet das forschungsteam ja
sogar mehr in diesem seltsamen signal
wir halten euch hier auf jeden fall auf
dem laufenden haben mit ihr kein video
zum thema und zu allen anderen themen
verpasst drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesslich den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter also hier mit aliens
der erste kontakt da geht es darum dass
wir vielleicht schon lange von aliens
beobachtet werden wie bitte ja und das
ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich also
wenn er darüber mehr wissen wollt
klickt auf das video und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran